front set very well this is a defining
moment defining moment for our union
words are important I believe and the
refugee crisis were facing not only us
but the region and the world puts our
deepest values even our identity to a
test it's a moment of truth to see if we
are really Europeans and if we are
really a union that's it our
responsibility to protect the life of
human beings and human rights and
solidarity among member states and
towards those that are in need but this
is also a test for our international
credibility don't think that we can go
around the world promoting human rights
if we don't guarantee the highest Asylum
standards inside the Union don't think
don't even imagine that we can promote
peace and cooperation among parties that
are at war in this moment if we don't
accept the other inside our own
communities and if we don't manage to
find unity among ourselves our external
credibility depends largely on our
internal coherence and consistency we
have to be aware of that don't imagine
that there is only an external response
to the crisis as there cannot be only an
internal response to the crisis the two
dimensions of our action of our identity
of our response reinforce each other or
weaken each other this is the truth like
it or not and we have to face it to be
credible preaching well is not enough we
must act well we must act fast and we
must act United today we present a
communication set in the way forwards
for all the external action needed to
address this crisis we all know there is
no quick magic fix to the crisis we have
around us
and most of the external actions we can
take and we are taking are going to give
results in the medium and long term
still it is important that we do that
now I know it is very difficult for
politicians to explain what is the
reason for taking actions that will pay
back in years sometimes but if we don't
do that responsibly generations that are
coming after hours we always face the
same problem again and again and let me
say that our external action finds us
United for once this is not enough
because we have to find internal unity
own internal domestic internal policies
but it is crucial for our action first
priority is saving lives
the president was outlining how much
we've stepped up our work in this
respect and how many lives that made it
possible to be saved second address the
root causes and I'll come back to that
third as important fight smugglers and
traffickers of human beings all around
the routes not only at sea all around
the routes also because this is a
security issue as the financial flow
around the criminal organizations and
networks can finance all kind of
activities that might be relevant also
for the European and international
security our strategy has been clear in
consistence since the beginning of our
mandates we cannot focus only on the
last mile of the tragedy but also on all
the steps of the refugees Odyssey most
of the people we see today coming to
Europe free from conflict and
persecution this is the first issue we
need to address for millions a flood
Syria between Syria and Iraq more than
ten millions have left their homes and
are internally displaced let me say one
thing we are rightly focused in these
months on minorities in need of
protection in the Middle East Christians
Kurds oh yes it is to support their
right to stay in the land and go back to
the communities they have been living in
for centuries but let me also say very
clearly that we cannot protect them only
when they are far away
from us we have the duty to protect them
also them and all their fellows also
when they come close to us the long-term
answer obviously is putting an end to
the conflicts and the wars facing the
threat of - starting processes of
national reconciliations the deal we
reached with Iran although primarily a
non-proliferation deal can open the way
to new possibilities and the work with
all our international and regional power
partners and all international and
regional powers in this direction has
already started
second we're working with the
international community mainly with the
UN agencies with the countries of origin
and transit and those who host an
impressive number of refugees with
mobilised almost 4 million euros in
monetary and development aid to assist
displaced Syrians within the country in
Syria itself in Jordan Lebanon Turkey
and Iraq there is a specific case a very
specific case which is Libya not a
country of origin but the country of
transit more than a country of transit I
would say an opal corridor that's why as
you know very well because we have
debated it several times in this very
same ma cycle all our daily and nightly
efforts are being spent together with
the UN and Voice Bernardino Leon to try
and reach a national unity government in
Libya that could allow us to partner
with the Libyan authorities on the
management of this corridor at the
moment but let me also say that it is
going to be very important and we are
working very much in this direction to
work to the south of Libya if we focus
only on the Libyan sea border forgetting
about the Libyan land border we will
never manage to solve the issue of the
corridor that's why I've started an
unprecedented dialogue with the
countries of the soil and in particular
with nature but not only nature and
today as you know we're putting forward
the proposal of a trust fund for Africa
to promote economic opportunities
development security and
the better management of migration in a
sense of partnership equal partnership
with our African countries and partners
the institutions will provide 1.8
million euros to this fund and I expect
all Member States all of them to do
their fair share you cannot ask for
international cooperation at European
level and then don't put the money for
it remember this when we come to discuss
the budget we have to show coherence in
our decisions original trust funds for
Syria has already kicked off as already
started in the last months and the first
contract that was opened through the
fund leads with schools and education
and let me stress this because I believe
that as we see that Syria is losing an
entire generation to war and exile we
have to invest in Syrian children that
is an investment not only for the future
of the country for the future of the
region but also to our security because
this is the best investment we can do
against terrorism and radicalization
third and I finish with fighting those
who trade on human life the smugglers
and the traffickers networks we're doing
this together with trunk countries of
transit in partnership and we're doing
this in the Mediterranean our novel
operation in the Mediterranean Sea has
now fulfilled the objectives of the
first phase we gathered intelligence and
information on the smugglers routes
assets and strategies even through the
first phase and just in this five weeks
in 16 cases we would have been able to
go after the smugglers bring them to
justice
and capture the vessels that's why I
proposed member states in Luxembourg in
over the last weekend where we had the
defense ministers and the foreign
ministers to move to phase 2 in the high
seas in full respect of international
law and to contribute I asked Member
States to contribute with their assets
to the mission because let me say this
is also an opportunity for us to show
that when we have political will and
sense of urgency and unity we can use
also our military
security tools that we already have but
there is something else I am proud of
that in this very first weeks of common
action in the Mediterranean we have
saved 1,500 lives of men and women at
sea through our operation it is not the
main purpose of the operation but this
is an important component of it the way
forward we will have the Valletta summit
on migration in November bringing
together leaders of the European and key
African countries those are part of the
Khartoum and the Rabat process as well
as the African Union Commission and the
Economic Community of Western Balkan
states Commission we will have the
high-level conference on the Western
Balkan route the two has have to be
dealt with at with the same kind of
attention and urgency that will bring
together young member states Western
Balkan countries and Turkey we need to
realize to conclude as Europeans that
this is not just the time for emotions
that is the easy part let me be cynical
as politicians we are not requested to
express our emotions we are requested to
take decisions that are consistent and
coherent with our emotions and be strong
on that emotions are not enough we need
to act and this is the time so I hope
that all institutions member states and
citizens public opinions because this
wave of emotion regards our public
opinions but this can change and we have
to be aware of that we have to finally
take responsibility to live up to our
values to the values of our history to
the challenges of the most difficult
times our history recently has faced and
the potential of our regional and global
role what is at stake as France said
very well is not only the life of human
beings and even one single life is
enough but also the state of our union
thank you